digamos que tengo un objeto que cuando
se encuentra fuera del agua su peso
fuera del agua es igual a 10 newtons
y lo vamos a sumergir en agua y tenemos
una báscula que funciona bajo el agua y
el peso de este objeto bajo el agua lo
cambiamos de color
el peso de este objeto bajo el agua
es igual a 2 newtons que está pasando
aquí pues el agua debe estar ejerciendo
alguna fuerza hacia arriba para
contrarrestar en parte 8 newtons del
peso original y esta diferencia es la
fuerza de flotación
una vez que ponemos el objeto en el agua
vamos a dibujar aquí el agua
y vamos a dibujar nuestro objeto
lo pongo aquí con forma de cubo pero
puede tener cualquier forma
me aseguro de que se note que está
sumergido en el agua
sabemos que tenemos el peso hacia abajo
el peso de nuestro objeto va a ir hacia
abajo y es de 10 newtons
y una vez que está en el agua tendremos
una fuerza hacia arriba que va a ser
8 newtons
y esta es la fuerza de flotación que
vimos en el vídeo anterior sobre el
principio de arquímedes
por lo que nuestra fuerza de flotación
fuerza de flotación es igual a 10 menos
8 minutos esto es lo que está empujando
hacia arriba este objeto pero esto ha
que es igual también a bueno esto va a
ser igual al peso del agua desplazada
entonces estos 8 newtons van a ser igual
y aquí es igual el peso del agua
desplazada pues es igual al volumen del
agua desplazada por lo que esto es igual
al volumen del agua por la densidad del
agua por la gravedad
como vamos a encontrar el volumen del
agua bueno el volumen del agua
es igual a 8 kilogramos
por metro sobre segundo al cuadrado que
es lo mismo que newton
/
la densidad del agua que de vídeos
anteriores supimos que era mil
kilogramos
por metro cúbico por la fuerza de
gravedad que sabemos es de 9.8 metros
sobre segundo al cuadrado
y si calculamos las unidades veremos que
nos quedan las unidades correctas pero
hagamos los cálculos
vamos a usar nuestra calculadora aquí
está vamos a dividir 8 entre
por 9.8 cerramos vemos igual
y nos queda aproximadamente que es igual
a 8.2 por 10 a la menos 4 metros cúbicos
así que solamente conociendo la
diferencia entre el peso de un objeto
fuera del agua y el peso al super here
lo en el agua se puede calcular su
volumen lo que es un buen juego para
cuando tengan fiestas en la piscina
presencia fuera del agua consiguen una
báscula a prueba de agua y psc dentro de
la alberca y podrán calcular su volumen
al encontrar el valor de la fuerza de
flotación mediante la diferencia en el
peso de algo fuera y dentro del agua se
puede encontrar su volumen y este puede
verse como un volumen muy pequeño este
de este ejemplo pero tengan en mente que
en un metro cúbico tenemos cero puntos 0
cuadrados
y esto a su vez es igual a 34 pulgadas
cuadradas
por lo que el objeto no es tan pequeño
como pensábamos en un principio
ahora hagamos otro problema vamos a
limpiar la pantalla
digamos que tengo madera de balsa y yo
sé que la densidad de esta madera de
balsa es igual a 130 kilogramos
sobre metro cúbico y tengo un gran cubo
de esta manera y lo que quiero saber es
qué porcentaje del cubo si yo lo fuera a
sumergir en agua éste es agua
este es mi cubo de balsa que estoy
poniendo aquí
lo que yo quiero saber
es qué porcentaje de este cubo se
encuentra sumergido en el agua
cómo hacemos esto para que este cubo
esté quieto
debemos tener flotabilidad
qué es la fuerza que actúa
que actúa de abajo hacia arriba es la
fuerza de flotabilidad
y esta fuerza debe ser igual al peso
este es mi fuerza de gravedad o el peso
de mi objeto cuál será la fuerza de
gravedad el peso del objeto por lo que
escribimos aquí la fuerza de gravedad es
igual al volumen de mi cubo de balsa por
la densidad del cubo de balsa por la
gravedad y cuál es la fuerza de
flotabilidad bueno
esta fuerza de flotabilidad va a ser
igual al volumen del agua desplazada y
que a su vez es igual al volumen del
objeto sumergido o de la parte sumergida
del objeto así que esto podemos poner lo
que es el volumen de la parte sumergida
de la parte sumergida del objeto por en
este caso es la densidad
del agua por la fuerza de gravedad
y ya que el bloque está estacionario
sabemos que estas dos fuerzas deben ser
iguales por lo que lo escribimos acá el
volumen de la madera por la densidad de
la madera por la gravedad va a ser igual
igual
el volumen sumergido por la densidad del
agua por la gravedad
podemos simplificar esto ya que en ambos
lados tenemos aquí la gravedad y nos
queda el volumen de la madera de balsa
por la densidad de la madera de balsa es
igual al volumen sumergido por la
densidad del agua y qué sucede si
dividimos ambos lados entre el volumen
de la madera de balsa y reacomodamos la
ecuación bueno nos va a quedar que el
volumen sumergido entre el volumen de el
bloque de madera de balsa va a ser igual
a la densidad del bloque de madera de
balsa entre la densidad del agua aquí
hice varias operaciones algebraicas
ahora estamos listos para resolver el
problema mi pregunta original era qué
porcentaje
del objeto está sumergido y es
exactamente esta parte qué porcentaje
del bloque está sumergido con respecto
al total
y esto es igual
sustituimos los valores
130 kilogramos sobre metro cúbico /
la densidad del agua que desde hace
varios vídeos la conocemos y es de mil
kilogramos sobre metro cúbico esto es
igual a punto 13 que es igual al 13% el
porcentaje del bloque que está sumergido
es el 13%
y esto me parece genial ya que de hecho
puede haber tenido cualquier forma este
objeto y aún así podríamos encontrar el
porcentaje sumergido nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo